okay that's what i was trying to say i
just remembered it you got it is that
the ex how's your arms doing by the way
what is up guys so we just got out of
watching candy man uh the 2020 edition
that takes place in 2019 no idea why
they chose to do it that way yeah i
can't think of a reason why we got
christian from double toasted holding
the camera for us i said i'll get you a
ticket
if you just hold the camera for like
roughly eight to ten minutes you know we
were both really looking forward to this
movie i i honestly barely remember the
first candyman movie which is the only
one i saw i saw a couple times when i
was like a kid and later on in life when
talking with people i realized oh it's
actually like kind of a deep movie and
you uh you're much more familiar with
like the franchise as a whole i went
into this and i don't think you actually
need to have seen the prior candyman
movie at all to understand this they do
a really
illustrative job
illustrative especially when you see
this movie that's gonna be even funnier
when you look back at this review going
through the events of the first one
without just doing a big exposition dump
the unfolding of the whole mysterious
narrative happens throughout the film i
was pleasantly surprised by it you know
it's got a lot of social commentary as
you'd expect and a lot of people credit
the first candyman movie for having like
a good approach being like a horror
movie mixed with some social commentary
i feel like this movie like double downs
on the social commentary but it never
over takes away from like the horror and
the character-driven narrative approach
i actually was
really impressed with this i thought
nina costa did a wonderful wonderful job
like it's very expressionate but john
before i just like go for the next few
minutes what would you say
step in there what'd you think i
actually quite enjoyed it a lot yeah no
i did too i really did and as you know a
fan of the first movie and every time
i've revisited it it is one of those
both horror and 90s movies and i'm like
wow i'm surprised at how much this is
held up and appreciated in value and so
seeing this you know i was really
excited but i also had some nerves about
it just because you know if you're
tackling very socially aware content now
there's a different way in which that
articulates and for the most part i feel
like they did a really nice job here
because this gives you all the candy man
stuff that you want while also weaving i
think really nicely into where the first
movie and the story starts which is you
know it's about this tapestry of urban
legend that has been contributed to and
morphed over time and so as a sequel but
also you know kind of soft reboot this
works in both directions so if you've
seen the original one and you know
certain names or certain places
references easter eggs yeah right
breakdown
that's the real
stuff like that it's not distracting and
it figures in in ways that are
significant but like you said it
anything you need to be caught up on
from the first movie the original movie
the movie will get that information to
you in a way that feels appropriate and
and in a way that's usually very
artistic because this movie centers
around an artist and it takes a lot of
cues from that i mean you know in the
first movie you're doing sort of a
research expedition and in this one
you're more delving just into the hues
and the emotions and the tones of the
candyman mythology in the story yeah
that's why i thought like upping the
stylistic approach to here is more than
just cool 20 20 soft reboot horror movie
look how awesome we look here this movie
manages to double down on the nuance of
it but having its stylistic approach is
truly a reflection oh my god i'm just so
good with the with the word choices
oh man um but
reflecting
i got so caught up in the whole
reflecting bit with the cinematography
of this film the stylistic approaches of
here the artistry on display with the
direction was reflective of the
character's journey here because this is
very character driven i thought yaya
abdulmatine i hope i'm saying his name
right i love this actor
and he's he's appearing in like a
gazillion more movies coming up and he
is phenomenal in this like he's so
subtle similar to
virginia madsen that's what i was gonna
you know you know when you watch this
film you just can't stop thinking about
virginia man that's how it goes
this character what he goes through here
is like this real obsessive insane
psychological dissent it's done in such
a way where like the first 20 to 30
minutes or something like i guess this
is more like a drama and not really a
horror film and then and then the horror
just slowly starts like
seeing the movie yeah and i like that's
my favorite kind of it's like dreadful
horror and that's the thing is it's easy
to misconceive candyman is just a
slasher movie and then you look at the
trailer and they're like it's gotta be a
bunch of people you gotta be a bunch of
kills and so yeah it's like you might be
taken aback by oh there's just a lot
more story here than i was initially
anticipating if you're not because it's
about this guy's journey absolutely yeah
it's not just what's going on with candy
man oh my god death like it's a real
character piece yes what is candy man
what does he mean to all these people
what is that legacy not just who's he
going to kill and how yeah because
some of my favorite kind of horror
elements are deal with obsession and
paranoia so i'm like i'm pretty biased
here yeah
these are saying to me these are like
the things i like right here also is
reflective in a lot of body horror ways
again i don't want to give this away of
what really goes on here but there are
some like pretty disturbing elements
that occur uh with the violence some
stuff that there were some people i
heard talk about this movie that i
thought dumbed it down to the point
where i'm like i guess it's not that
violent there were some moments where i
was really like
very unsettled i was like cringing quite
a bit also tiana paris more than just
you know the wife to the main character
like she is also great she has a lot
more nuance
written into her character as well that
i
wasn't really anticipating would go on
and she i'll just say this she also has
an arc of her own too that i thought
made that movie just as powerful the
only issues i really have with this film
some of the dialogue can feel very just
your
i don't want to say the word preachy
that's not the right choice of words
sometimes with these jordan pl films i
think they can be more subtle with the
handling while getting a social
commentary messages along whereas there
were times here where i'm like i i think
you're really
laying it out clearly for me and i think
though plotting wise with the third act
there were some things that occur that
i thought perhaps a little bit too
condensed or a little bit rushed i'm not
exactly sure what it is it's kind of
hard to do a just watched on this one
because there's a lot to absorb they're
seeing so much here
it's psychological it gave me pretty
much what i wanted and a little bit more
than what i expected yeah and i don't
think the trailers properly allude to
just how uh deep this movie actually is
much of a journey yeah because it deals
a lot with like gentrification
especially generational trauma for sure
and i mean if i had any gripes it is
like i think the original film and i'm
not to keep being that guy because i
don't actually think that this you know
pales in comparison i think it's a
really worthy follow-up but that
original film i think is like 10 minutes
longer and i could use maybe 10 more
minutes of this because there is
yeah there is like an economics of
storytelling at times that works really
well and sometimes you can feel the sort
of modern economics of storytelling
that's probably the only gripe i had but
so much of this gave me yeah just so
much rich character stuff style tone and
yeah you music too it was amazing at
times it felt like a mood piece
absolutely it feels like they're
building off the philip glass score from
the first one with a lot of these very
like ambient and organ driven sounds
like it has a very rot feeling
underneath that makes you uneasy the
entire time for me i'd i'd probably give
this like a solid 9 out of 10 if i if i
had a rating system ever if i had a
consistent rating system once in my life
this feels like a the thing you go
without a 10 on this one and i feel like
it's all a 9 out of 10 for me is is like
right up there yeah absolutely christian
come over here for a second let me let
me yeah yeah i really liked it i would
echo everything that you've said i
discovered candyman later i've rewatched
it when i was a kid i thought it was
ginger dead man and pumpkinhead and all
those like bad kind of horror films but
no it's a horror film that has a lot to
say and this is such a worthy successor
to that and i'm really thankful that you
guys asked me to come out thank you so
much i hope you enjoy the car ride with
us oh yeah it's going to be a blast i'm
sure yeah this guy's so boring
so boring just doesn't get back behind
the camera
i was so tired when he showed up
and then he'd like his energy woke me up
and i'm like now i think i'm ready to
watch candy man no now i have no
so much for that double date i was
hoping to ask you on later with john
joining us on that double date
i'm so confused but okay the numbers
don't add out there this is called
rapport and chemistry and i think we've
captured it on camera here today i don't
think so i'm sorry that's not how you
said we talked about this in the car
right now i don't think we talked about
one job
oh yes yeah okay yes and
i'm you're never gonna make it in this
business i know i agree guys go follow
christian online he appears on double
toast don't i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry i don't even follow you
all right fine fine all right guys well
thanks for being here i think we got a
thumbnail pose if you did subscribe
click that notification like button you
know whatever the usual crap people say
on youtube
[Music]